let's jump to this next story though
while we're talking about getting
nothing done
this is actually something getting done
actually timcast.com reports oklahoma
governor signs law banning abortion from
moment of conception
this is interesting they crafted this
abortion ban off of liberal arguments
leftist arguments
they say
house bill 4327 went into effect
immediately upon signing and bans
abortion unless the procedure is
necessary to save the life of the mother
or is the result of rape sexual assault
or incest that has been reported to law
enforcement removing a miscarried fetus
or ectopic pregnancy will not be
considered abortion there it is
every argument from the left has been
addressed yeah it's brilliant it
basically bans elective abortion
that's it
this is the the only state in the nation
to have banned elective abortion
most i believe there's maybe like a
dozen or two states that have uh
elective abortion to the point of
viability or dire at viability meaning
the baby can survive and then you have
seven states plus washington dc that
allow you to abort a baby at nine months
now hold on i can already hear the the
liberals screaming i did not say it is a
common occurrence that is not my point
my point is it is illegal
and so it happens sometimes
i don't care if it's rare if it's not an
issue and it's not happening all the
time why is it legal why should it be
allowed additionally as for this law
this appears to be the majority opinion
of this country
that people want abortion to be legal
only in certain circumstances
well here it is this is what oklahoma's
done right
i thought that maybe i'm wrong roe v
wade does that not protect
uh or does that not say that the states
cannot ban abortion it certainly does so
how is this guy signing a bill that bans
it the same way that california doesn't
enfor enforce immigration laws whoa
that's right california status
they're a sanctuary state and they will
not cooperate or work with federal law
enforcement you know i respect the
state's rights to do that i'm not it's
not even about if i agree with it or not
i respect that that's how the the united
states works that's pretty cool
yeah i i i absolutely don't i do not you
don't like that governors can go rogue i
don't like the governors can go rogue
they got to because desantis man he he
was like a beacon during the covet
pandemic florida thrived sure there's
differences between florida being like
we're not going to agree with agree with
federal guidelines on a lot of these
things and we're going to run our state
the way we want is another thing when at
a federal level when it comes to things
like illegal immigration
or slavery or abortion we're like there
are certain things that this country has
not made that has made illegal now the
reason why i don't like it is if you
look at what california's done
there they by by by not enforcing
immigration law
they inflate their population to a
certain degree and then uh congressional
seats are are are apportioned based on
populations and electoral college and
electoral college means california got
an extra vote in the presidency so when
people say illegal immigrants vote let
me correct you they do not individually
go out and vote but doesn't matter we
elect our president through the
electoral college they don't need to
vote their presence grants an extra vote
to california california lost a vote i
think in the last due last census but
before this constantly just allowing
people to come in granting them free
health care they're putting a strain on
on on the surrounding states and imagine
you are you know nevada
or idaho or or arizona and you've got
people going into california
staying there in violation of the law
and then they can cross over from the
from the west into your state that's
already dealing with a border crisis
that's an issue for other states that's
infringing upon those states rights this
is the kind of issue that literally
resulted in the civil war the south they
had slaves and they said the north
should abide by federal law right well
the federal law had the fugitive slave
act and the north was not abiding by it
i mean i that i agree with that i think
the problem uh i think slavery shouldn't
should have been uh uh abolished the
issue for the self though was that if
the federal government was not going to
be able to enforce these laws
then why should there be a union at all
well there you go well that's the issue
it's the federal government so you know
the 10th amendment reserve power states
should be able to do all these things x
y and z that are not granted in the
constitution the federal government so i
think a hybrid of what you guys are
saying is sort of workable the problem
with the sanctuary state standing on the
immigration issue
is that it's not being enforced like the
federal government could go and enforce
the law in california they are electing
not to do that they are electing to
break their own federal our own federal
statutes that's my problem because they
agree
with the policy decision in california
that overrides a federal statute someone
should be going to jail on this and
enforcing this law and allowing our
immigration authorities to go in there
and not
uh do that but the thing the way they
work it is they basically go into all
the jails and
illegal immigrants come over and make
first contact with law enforcement and
the ice detainers aren't applied they're
just like we're not doing we're we are
literally we california are not doing it
it's a federal offense someone should go
prosecute the governor i suppose you
know we can say this too you're just
looking back on my what i literally said
it's an issue of our our personal morals
and world views as to what we think is
fair and acceptable yeah because weed
for instance california is like it's
legal here and the feds aren't gonna
we're gonna protect you from the feds
that was basically and then the feds
were like all right they proved their
point we're not messing with california
anymore no that's not true well for the
most part yeah i think that obama was
like said in the troops kind of but the
a was storming
when i was there in 2006 it was very
dang it was very dangerous to have a
weed card but then by 2010 it was very
cool there are there are some instances
i suppose i i think the illegal
immigration issue is probably
what i mostly disagree with and i think
maybe the state's asserting themselves
is probably a good thing so maybe i'll
walk back a little bit
the thing about the illegal immigration
is that it affects the entirety of the
country in a very serious negative way
politically it it actually takes
congressional seats from somewhere else
and gives it to a state so it's almost
like stealing influence whereas the weed
thing isn't that big of a deal
and like i was just saying you know when
the north was refusing to return slaves
that was a good thing the north saying
screw you we don't care about your law
okay that i agree with so maybe there
are positions where the states should
say screw off to the federal government
could the federal government just refuse
to acknowledge the population growth of
california if they know that there's
illegal immigration well that's what the
trump administration tried to do with uh
how they were doing the census back in
2020 they wanted to not include illegal
aliens right so that that's the whole
the whole point of the sense is it goes
to the electoral college and a couple
other things but that's what he tried to
do that the census was basically you're
saying you're counting them wrong you're
counting illegal people in the census in
the census of supposed to count
americans because
we only have x amount of electoral votes
there's no new ones it's not like you're
getting another one like tim said i
think what most people don't get is it's
not like california got a plus one and
everybody else stayed the same somebody
lost one
that's the problem that was a matter
that that trump was trying to take on
he's like why why should they lose one
if they're gay if their population is
remaining the same and another
population is increasing with illegally
uh present individuals that was a that
was the heart of the matter and they
didn't want to like
show who was legal they didn't want
people coming in being like show me your
papers because they thought it was like
nazi germany and people would get
arrested families get broken up that's
why there was so much resistance to it
yeah i i think that uh that's a lie like
i i i think they know exactly what
they're doing who's it like california
yeah oh yeah for sure they do and so but
they'll come out and be like it's racist
sure it's easy it's easy to say it right
it's like it works you know all the
headlines everybody's a racist if you're
not for illegal immigration i'm for
legal immigration and i'm just not for
illegal immigrants
reckon our society what's what's your
ethnic background uh indian so you're
the indian face of white supremacy yeah
yeah i'm brown lives matter oh yeah
yeah it's it how how do regular people
fall for that stuff right calling larry
elder the black face of white supremacy
but it's just easy nuts it's just an
easy epithet that's meaningless and it's
like we were talking about earlier it
doesn't solve anything no one's having
an actual conversation they're just like
oh that sounds cool let me go blast it
on social media and get popular it's
used so much now though that it's lost
all of its meaning yeah i think it's
roman supremacy and that we didn't talk
about we talk about empires and how
empires fall but like the roman empire
still so heavily entrenched the roman
catholic church the roman and like the
roman i don't know where else you want
to go with it but why the romans the
roman empire were basically the vestige
of the roman empire right now the roman
catholic church is basically the holy
roman empire that lasted for another
thousand years after the roman empire
fell apart uh maybe a little too and
then they call it derivative i mean if
you want to go back you can keep going
back beyond that and talk about all the
other people could the romans were
pretty unique in history like white we
double white supremacy it's really roman
supremacy the slave estate of the roman
empire i don't agree
i'm seeing a lot of that tonight there
wasn't
what's in your water i mean
the europeans were
you know it's an amalgamation of the
roman it was over it fractured they all
became they're kind of similar but
different you know cultures then we got
colonization it's a really interesting
history it's fascinating the roman
empire breaks up then you get all these
you know countries emerge sharing a
language in some ways and not in others
then they go off and colonize other
areas compete with each other going to
war it is pretty crazy yeah they took
germany france and spain in italy the
romans and then of course damn pirates
but i i just think there's uh
there
there is a majority privilege right i i
think when you look to any country the
people who look mostly like each other
typically are you know more likely to
work with each other in china they're
all racist to people who aren't chinese
so these things they happen but
to to blindly just come out when someone
has a legitimate critique or political
concept and to insult them as racist to
call to say simultaneously that only
white people can be racist but candace
owens is a white supremacist i'm just
kind of like you lost me because i don't
think you're actually saying words
anymore i think it's just a cult well
i'm not a racist i'm just a genocidal
dictator remember they skipped their
problems
yeah the daily beast said that so
you know i wonder what it feels like to
be called a racist i think do you think
we're all a little racist small r
racist i think that you're right more
that it's more about familiarity bias
people aren't necessarily racist just
whatever you've been around my family
first yeah when my family first came
here my dad has eight brothers and
sisters and their wives are husbands and
their kids in one you know one place i
don't know that we were racist but they
didn't know the world they they hung out
with indian people not because they
didn't want to hang out with other
people they just didn't know what they
had to do my mother were sorry to the
grocery store for 10 years because you
know what else to wear i would like to
go on record and just say i hate
everybody equally
that's smart there you go there you go
thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast but if you
want to check out the full show live
tune in monday through friday at 8pm and
if you want more special access content
head over to timcast.com and become a
member your membership helps sustain
this company keep our journalists
employed makes this show happen and you
will get access to exclusive members
only segments of the tim cast irl
podcast and there's a massive library to
check out so again go to timcast.com or
tune in monday through friday at 8 pm
we'll see you all there